al ángel de swinton
francesc antich
a katherine matildas swinton nacida en
londres pero de espíritu escocés no le
gusta la palabra actriz
prefiere intérprete de un cine que desde
los 80 la aplaude maestra camaleónica y
una moda que la reclama y como propio
[Música]
tóxica
tras desaparecer en decenas de rostros
con memoria repite la fórmula de su
carrera ser creadora con su amigo joe el
cineasta tailandés apichatpong
weerasethakul juntos parten de jessica
una agricultura de orquídeas para
retratar un fuerte bang bang que
interrumpe sus sueños y la lleva a un
viaje de descubrimiento por colombia
en casa legado en el marco del festival
de cine francés conversamos
tilda swinton en que son muchísimas
gracias por acompañarnos en france 24 es
mayor el honor es mío gracias por
invitarme yo bis front you guys de
tailandia tú vives en escocia pre
memoria es un maravilloso filme
colombiano cuáles fueron los rasgos o
reverberaciones que hicieron que
eligiera jce colombia como el lugar muy
bueno que infesta me ha
dejado salten universidades buscamos un
lugar que tuviera algo que
reconociéramos como extranjeros como
extraños y lo encontramos aquí cuando
decidimos trabajar juntos sabíamos que
no queríamos trabajar en tailandia en
esta película no queríamos trabajar en
escocia queríamos encontrar un lugar
nuevo
y queríamos que se tratara de esta
travesía de una persona extraña
pekín que canta las reverberaciones pero
que no forma parte del entorno y el
virus cartagena al festival de cine me
escribió y me dijo es aquí es colombia y
yo vine poco después y estuve de acuerdo
cuáles son las reverberaciones
wen which sound places creo que hay una
forma en la que algunos lugares
arrastran traumas en el presente desde
el pasado eso es reconocible y eso está
aquí en colombia en escocia en tailandia
y de eso se trata el trabajo de joe en
la mayoría de sus últimas películas así
que encontramos eso aquí y también es el
hombre acogiera la película que hicimos
dos extranjeros como una película
colombiana es increíblemente importante
para nosotros
memoria wilber memoria representar a
colombia en los oscar felicidad es por
eso a la vez que jessica es parte ya de
bogotá y pijao como fue este viaje por
el insomnio y los recuerdos
resuelve muy lentamente y en silencio y
receptiva mente
en el lander es muy interesante cuando
aterricé aquí el otro día inmediatamente
me sumergía en una especie de estado
similar al de jessica a través de la
película like my
es como si mis oídos hubieran crecido y
siento que gracias al trabajo del joe y
a la película que hicimos escucho cosas
en bogotá y en el quindío donde vamos a
llevar la película a casa
de una manera que no necesariamente
escucho otros lugares que visito me
siento muy en sintonía con esto
mauer that many times y sé que a menudo
te describen por tu rol o tu disfraz
pero de qué forma el personaje de
jessica ha nutrido tu interés por la
bondad por la humanidad en su manera
no pienso en jessica como un papel
ciertamente no pienso en ella como un
personaje no es una palabra que me gusta
utilizar porque creo que es algo que tal
vez viene del teatro que no es algo con
lo que yo trabajando en el cine me
sienta realmente identificada pero
ciertamente más que cualquier otro
retrato que es una palabra que prefiero
en el que haya trabajado en el pasado
sexting ha sido una invitación a
quitarme cosas de encima y en muchos
sentidos a estar más cerca de mí misma y
de mi propio ritmo mi propia velocidad
y mi propio pulso de lo que nunca antes
había podido hacer
así que para mí es una vuelta a algo
mucho más cercano a mi yo más joven casi
a mí yo infantil y guarda relación con
tu escritura porque empezar este
escribiendo
racing me da lástima haber dejado de
escribir y la forma en la que empecé a
actuar realmente fue la causa de que
dejara de escribir he estado escribiendo
a través de la interpretación durante
muchos años este retrato es
definitivamente algo que ocupó la parte
de escritor de mí misma tanto como la de
bailarinas
no creo que jessica haya sido hecha por
un actor realmente creo que está más
cerca de la danza que de cualquier otra
cosa pero sobre todo fue hecho por un
par de escritores
por eso memoria e inició con una carta a
joe en khan y siguió con las mejores
fiestas de pijao is the best parte es
empujado al danza y el baile de una
carta al baile de eso se trata en cierto
modo abarcamos el corazón creativo de
esta película creo que es un buen punto
tienden al ser performer como eres con
tus amigos sientes que te diviertes más
que un actor profesional profesional
estoy seguro de que los verdaderos
profesionales se divierten de una manera
que no puedo imaginar sólo sé que me
gusta y tengo que trabajar con gente
y no soy alguien que trabaja sola o sea
vivo en solitario en cierto modo pero me
gusta trabajar con mis amigos no sé me
imagino que hay todo tipo de cosas
mágicas que los profesionales hacen bien
pero en el mundo en el territorio
amateur en el que vivo nos divertimos
mucho
frans steyn conversations tus amistades
y las conversaciones definen tu carrera
desde la universidad pero como ha sido
unir el cisco aprendido con derek jarman
y
con la camaradería de tu linaje familiar
militar
creo que cuanto más envejezco más siento
que siguiendo la tradición de mi familia
hay familia expresión
recuerdo que una vez se me citó mal
diciendo que yo vivía la vida de un
soldado
sé lo suficiente sobre la vida de los
soldados para saber que no vivo en la
vida de un soldado
pero sí creo que hay ritmos y tendencias
y habilidades que los soldados aprenden
que yo también aprendí esa camaradería
y tener un objetivo compartir un
objetivo y no dejarse abatir por el frío
los walkie-talkies comer a todas horas
del día y de la noche
pero sobre todo la camaradería creo que
eso es algo que aprendí yo vi a mi padre
disfrutar de eso toda su vida y a mi
hermano también y de tal palo tal
astilla
vemos risk and universe los universos
más recientes en los que has trabajado
son los de wes anderson y pedro
almodóvar como has desarrollado tus
llamados procesos autobiográficos con
cada uno de ellos
en muchos sentidos es interesante que
preguntes eso porque es de todos mis
camaradas
yo diría que el cine the west y pedro
requiere menos autobiografía creo que
trabajar con ellos es algo particular en
mi vida laboral
ambos trabajan dentro de una especie de
léxico que ha construido durante muchos
años la que tengo la suerte como
cinéfila y fan de cada uno de ellos de
conocer bien
y por lo tanto cuando me meto en sus
escenarios dejó más de mí misma diría yo
y felizmente y gratamente y realmente es
intrigante hacerlo
yo diría que ambos cineastas son
maestros
y han establecido un tipo de paisaje que
es muy particular que si me hubiera
dicho hace no sé 15 años que trabajaría
con wes anderson o si me hubieran dicho
hace dos años que trabajaría con pedro
habría dicho que sería poco probable la
idea de ser invitada a su mundo es
exótico para mí estoy muy agradecida
y justamente que supone para ti ser
chica almodóvar
[Risas]
es un honor increíble
quizás después de todo soy una mujer
es realmente increíble él es
extraordinario me sentí como en una
especie de escuela del cine cuando
trabajé con él aprendí tantísimo sobre
me reportaba hitchcock por la forma en
que hitchcock se olvida decir siempre
deja que la cámara cuente la historia y
el diálogo
él realmente dirige la cámara y estar en
sintonía con la forma en que dirige es
como encontré la forma de ser dirigida
por él
realmente disfruté abandonarme a eso
vengan
estar vestida de rojo y ser como una
actriz era como una verdadera actriz en
el sentido de que nunca había trabajado
realmente con él es decir hago de actriz
así que estaba trabajando con un tipo de
material con un tipo de emoción con lo
que no estoy acostumbrado a trabajar y
eso era realmente exótico with sally
potter in orlando gonzález potter y
orlando contribuiste e isa la identidad
queer ahora con pedro en la voz humana
vice otra salida a la mujer desesperada
de cocteau
así entiendes el arte como una máquina
de cambio de empatía
y
creo que el arte es nuestra mejor
apuesta y
creo que es un portal hacia lo que
deseamos lo que tenemos y lo que soñamos
y corremos el riesgo de ignorarlo porque
nos va a dar lo que necesitamos es como
una vitamina que necesitamos
el cambio es lo único con lo que
contamos no contamos con nada más y si
no éramos ese hecho estaremos en
problemas
solo tenemos que abrazar el caos y el
arte nos ayudará a hacer eso y como en
memoria los recuerdos
si la propuesta en memoria es compartir
una memoria colectiva y creo que una muy
profunda
de todos los filósofos y los grandes
pensadores la propuesto durante siglos
pero creo que es realmente bueno que lo
recordemos que siento
como diría mccartney en este mundo en
que vivimos hay una moda de amnesia de
amnesia colectiva desde lo político
parece que es muy valioso que se anime a
la gente a olvidar las cosas y lo que
necesitamos es animarnos realmente a ser
educados sobre la historia y hacer
también simplemente sensibles a la
historia que conocemos profundamente es
una propuesta radical marco creo que es
la que nos recuerda memoria
hilda por fin es útil da para concluir
como apostador a inmortal que te de
nóminas sientes que todavía estás dando
tus primeros pasos que estás
improvisando
estando totalmente totalmente no sabía
que había dicho eso pero lo sostengo me
gusta no saber a dónde voy a ir después
y me gusta dejarme llevar y sentir los
cambios y ser curiosas no me gusta mucho
saber lo que estoy haciendo
y zona de confort es girar una esquina
abrir una puerta y ver un horizonte
totalmente nuevo y espero seguir
haciéndolo durante mucho tiempo me
siento como de unos 7 años y espero que
siga siendo así durante mucho tiempo
espero que nos encontremos en unos 100
años entonces está sin duda totalmente
porque ha sido un placer
y a ustedes muchísimas gracias por esta
entrevista hasta en que tienen más
contenidos en france 24 punto com
al mando
murphy
la gente
pero dentro de tres con experience
[Música]